tech experts are gathering in Southern
California this morning to fight the
growing threat of so-called deep fakes
that's the name given to videos that are
manipulated to change their message or
even change who's in them Jonathan
Vigliotti looks at a new weapon in the
battle against that problem that we've
been reporting on since last year I have
no lines in this video
then I had in the last season
I'm sorry for that when it comes to deep
fakes even gameofthrones leap character
John Snow isn't immune this digitally
manipulated video shows him apologizing
for the series finale
I'm sure while some of these videos are
designed to entertain others are raising
serious concerns in this deep fake
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg appears
to be speaking about global domination
on CBS News his digital platform cbsn
imagine this for a second one man with
total control of billions of people
stolen down
despite CBS asserting trademark
infringement and asking Facebook to take
the video down the company has refused
pointing to First Amendment concerns 20
years ago we worried about fake content
in a court of law but we didn't really
worry about it going live on YouTube
Twitter and Facebook
honey Farid is a professor of computer
science at the University of California
Berkeley we take the video we track
facial expressions and head movements he
gave us an advance look at his new
software program that compares real
videos to supposedly
altered once he wants to offer it to
mainstream media outlets to help detect
deep fakes ahead of the upcoming
elections 190 of those measurements and
then we ask how distinct are they and
can they distinguish from the real from
the fake we will give you the ability to
upload the videos we will run them
through our analysis and then we will
tell you what we think well it's great
that you're placing this in the hands of
the media but do you worry that it's
ultimately a drop in the bucket when
you've got social media of course it's a
drop in the bucket the solution is not
just technology the solution is
technology good reporting better digital
citizens better companies better
policies and then he had a press
conference in the Rose Garden this
altered video of House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi which falsely showed her slurring
her words has been viewed more than
three million times on social media with
no clear way to stop it
the Speaker Pelosi video was not funny
it was meant to impugn her and intend to
create chaos within the party and it
worked and it worked and a statement
facebook tells CBS News leading up to
2020 we know that combating
misinformation is one of the most
important things we can do we continue
to look at how we can improve our
approach and the systems we've built the
one does not need any great imagination
to envision even more nightmarish
scenarios that would leave the
government the media and the public
struggling to discern what is real and
what is fake and a House Intelligence
Committee meeting last week
federal officials expressed concern
there's no easy fix the audience I'm
most worried about is actually not young
people in social media it is the older
generation who's come to this technology
late
you could then have the president say
anything we'll do anything I want right
imagine the implications for fraud
imagine how this could disrupt our
democratic elections imagine how it can
incite violence for CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti Long Beach California
Adam Schiff pointed out there's some
real nightmare scenarios here yeah we're
at a moment where we're thinking about a
conflict with with Iran what if
something surfaced in that it's a it's a
it's a match into a powder keg and
you've reported on this before yeah back
last year and I keep thinking you know
even if there is corrective technology
you know a lie can travel around the
world before the truth gets out of bed
exactly so fast